of that or it could be 25.
whatever it is so it was going it
initially was going to be
um it was a percentage
and so
your amendment is leaving it
open
for discussion
on those funds that have not been
reimbursed
um
i i think i think the intent here
was to avoid the duplication of benefits
uh concern that had been raised by the
uh
homeland security uh and i think that's
where the to the extent they're not
eligible for federal benefits comes from
but what i think this may also do
is open up
this new statute
as a mechanism for the governor with
fiscal and council approval to
pay assistance not related to a federal
disaster area so i think it makes it
quite broad in my in my interpretation
and i'm not sure if that's the intent
here or not
i don't think your microphone's on sorry
thank you um
i think that was a concern we have with
the bill
that the bill itself was very open-ended
that the governor could just pass on 300
million dollars to you know peoria uh
for the fun of it and so the whole bill
this this addressed the duplication of
efforts but i think that um
representative turcotte and i actually
both share the concern that the bill
itself was incredibly open-ended and i
don't know how um
going back to fix that i
chris sent a copy of the original bill
and
that was specific to the july and august
um
disasters
that does not seem to be in
the doesn't seem to be in four or nine
but it was in the original bill
um so i think we've i think we wanted to
um
not not just limit it to these two
um and that's that was one of the
reasons why the bill came over
to us
the way it did
yeah in which case it is so open-ended
that the governor could just
allot any amount of money to any
municipality
if well
yeah
let's let's take a look at the
amendment that i
put in and i think that
hopefully
this has kind of narrowed the scope
of of what we're doing
and um
so
i think we
well if you if people are in agreement
with my amendment
then i think we can
just
ignore this amendment
what says a municipality may apply to
the division of homeland security and
emergency management that's the state
agency yeah that's the state
the only state funds it's only state
right um
not to exceed
50 of the non-federal share
so tell me again what that means in
vernacular
so what this means
what that means is that
fema will pay will
reimburse the community at whatever
percentage
75 or 90
and then the community could ask for
half of the match so if it's
12.5
or 5
but that's what that 50 means is the
half of the match
for
eligible
of the non-federal share of projects
that were eligible so they payment as
paid and now the community is saying oh
i
can't afford to
so it's clear that the
and and the reason the reason that we
had um
homeland security in there is because
they will
set up some sort of process or rules or
something
sorry but this is good this is we will
create a rule
because the intent of sue prentice's
bill i think was this
yeah and i guess my i wanted to make
sure that i understand division of
homeland security and emergency
management is the state agency not the
federal so that was mm-hmm
is it catherine
okay
[Music]
it's uh it's really hard
and
just a second i'll be with you one of
the things that jen explained
is that
fema
let's say you replace a culvert okay and
you complete that work
fema will pay you for that work
and then
next month
you complete
i know another caller then they will pay
you for that
and so
the um
the community could then apply
for money for the first culvert
okay once it's completed once fema's
gives you the money
and then you could apply for the second
culvert
but we would you know or it could be
five years from now
when
the last
culvert that you had to replace
gets replaced
and
fema is all reimbursement correct
so
the town has to put out the money
complete the project and then fema will
reimburse the town
and they can get the money through 409
as a loan
right
so the way this is reading
i don't see that there's a potential for
duplication of effort
so we don't need is that the way am i
reading it correctly that way because
that's how i read it so we don't need
15.50
because
that would be my
thought yes
is
that's correct
okay
but
if i understand
i've learned more about fema in the last
three
i mean you know i knew what the letter
stood for
but as i understand a fema comes in
and identifies the projects that will
qualify
up front
okay
okay and so the towns know
which
projects are going to be approved
now
if you decide you want to put
butterflies
on the culvert
then fema may not pay for the
butterflies on the culvert
but they will pay for
the culvert
you have to follow the fema public
assistance guidance right
in order to be
eligible for reimbursement of disaster
projects what i'm saying is that may not
always be
you may not always be able to do that in
the middle of an emergency and you're
trying to get going
yeah remember
this is not
emergency
you know the emergency is
that
loan that you ask
for
emergency
right
to
whatever time period right and fema
defines emergency work and the
definition of emergency work and it's a
category of reimbursement
and then you go on to
developing your projects for
reimbursement to you know
replace this whole road and it's not
emergency work it's
whatever the term is what's
what's the turnaround time for you know
the point of a disaster and when fema
comes in for the emergency work it seems
like it's quite short
so
the process
let's just talk about
gesture
the process for that is
we need that threshold requested
presidential disaster declaration get
that and then go back to
all those towns that had disasters and
start working through their projects
identifying what roads what bridges what
culverts etc
that'll take years so
in
this case
we're projecting that challenge will
save money this summer so that's a year
later
that the work that they've been doing is
developed into a project and we know
what's eligible they followed all their
procurement they followed up guidelines
etc cetera and you know we'll take a
look at all their receipts et cetera et
cetera and reimburse them for projects
in
the case of that or
we have we didn't see
month after everything happened and some
of the repairs
temporary repairs had already been done
because we had gut roads
and some of those projects where they've
already done it we just call it a day
have a nice day
fast track those so that they can get
paid for those projects that are already
completed
and then work on developing the larger
culverts bridges
26 miles away whatever
how likely is it that a town would go
off and do something that would not be
approved by fema like you know the
butterflies it seems like you're talking
about a lot of money you're talking
about a lot of safety
seems to me the towns would be highly
motivated to do it right
because
so part of what
part of it is education of communities
of disasters so like cheshire selling
counties hadn't seen a disaster for a
number of
years so
ensuring that the towns
know
the process etc is
extremely important
and they may not because of turnover i
mean we could have gone out and done
training however many years ago and
they've turned over their entire staff
so part of our responsibility at the
state
is to make sure that communities
understand the fema public assistance
program
which changes on a
pretty consistent basis
okay so
um
i guess uh represent murray you just uh
are going to uh withdraw this
amendment
yeah with joe in the face of your
amendment i don't see that this is
necessary i don't see that there's a
duplication of effort with the new
amendment okay thank you
all right
are there any other comments on
amendment
okay seeing none could i have a motion
please
thank you second a second thank you
heath and murray
all those in favor of the amendment
please signify by saying
i okay
four zero on the amendment
and could i have a motion
to um
okay i have an otpa by representative
petri
do i um seconded by uh representative
heath
and peace
representative murray hi
president peter's ots
yes
chair the vote on 2022 1578 is
okay thank you
all right that's all
this messy stuff we have to do today
but if you think this is messy stuff
just wait
we got
the finance got
10 more bills today
okay
that paul has identified as needing to
come to finance
so
and of the 10
you'll never guess how many finance
curve division 2 gog
six
okay
well
what i understand from paul
is that we can meet next friday
afternoon
no
this friday
yeah
oh okay
she'll get married without you
okay well that's okay you know um
so
i will um
[Music]
i
so
i think he meant this friday yeah i i
think i hope i clarified that the 22nd
yeah
and then of course monday
tuesday
and we'll exec
these 10 bills on wednesday of next week
in the afternoon
so whatever
whatever we have we have to
work on quickly
uh one
yeah
i think that may have been sorry to
bring everyone down further 10 in
addition to the other 14 that we already
had identified correct oh yeah yeah
yeah
100 depends what depends what happens
thursday what passes of course but i
think it could be up to a couple dozen
for the full committee
we have an exec session on tuesday
and
yes those the exec session on tuesday
is to cover the seven bills
that
we had
okay
uh we have two
janet sent a notice about 25 minutes ago
yeah so you'll see that in your email
yeah but anyhow i think it's
then the the remaining we will do on
wednesday
yes
in the afternoon
so what we'll have is
however long the exec session takes on
tuesday morning
i may in fact schedule that at nine
o'clock
and so that will give us
um
you know the rest of that day
and half of
half of wednesday
i know
[Laughter]
it's amazing
it's amazing the things we learned
what
what i would do is schedule it for uh
the 29th
so anyhow i just i just wanted to let
you know that uh next week is um
going to be really you know friday and
then next week is going to be crunch
time so
it's unfortunate that they only gave us
um
three days four days to
take care of all the bills all the
second committee bills but
unfortunately that's what happened so
yes i know
well did they table it or did they enter
yeah interim study it yeah
yeah well i i was talking to joe ribson
this morning
about about that
and
what we're going to do is um
probably
august or september we're gonna have
another meeting
um
because
obviously there were a lot of questions
yeah well
you know and
yeah
a lot of there were a lot of questions
and so i think we need to get those
questions answered
and then we'll put the bill in again for
well those are the kinds of things that
that we need to uh
you know the i guess the problem is if
it comes in by individual name then what
is doe gonna do to
cleanse the names
okay and that i don't have an answer for
so
okay would you like to uh move over to
d.o.e janet
no oh okay just just thought i'd check
so um
i will not be scheduling the education
bills we we can only schedule the bills
that have passed by
one o'clock
on thursday
because they have to have 24-hour notice
okay
and um
monday
i'm not going to be here but joe will be
running the committee this month this
morning yeah remember you said
you said that
that's all right
and you said you told me you couldn't
start to one o'clock yeah we can start
early
on monday oh you can if you want well it
does it's probably already posted but
there's a poster but no
then
yes monday tuesday and wednesday
let me look at
yeah
okay if we make it
okay so if we make it 10 on monday okay
so
one on friday
on monday
i think
i think nine
i'm gonna do the exact session
on tuesday
yeah nine on tuesday
and then we'll probably have to do
nine on wednesday
and i'll schedule the exact exact
session for like
i'm just concerned about division two
getting through
all of their bills um division one had
three
and um
oh maybe they've got a few more than
that because
this was 10 extra ones
and so
um
i will schedule the exact session on
wednesday at three
yeah
because that'll get you know
i don't know how much time
all these bills are gonna take
no no the hearings have already taken
place all we have to do is have work
sessions
okay
session
i know there's no session
no
no next
not next thursday
yeah the fifth
unless we have some sort of catastrophe
but i'm not planning on it
okay
no
thanks
okay
so uh joe will you do the blurb on
right
you